>>> WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS ON THE
JUSTE DEPARTMENT'S
VESTIGATION OF JANUARY 6th.
LET'S GO TO OUR POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT SARA MURRAY.
SARA, TELL OUR VIEWERS WHAT
YOU'RE LEARNING.
>> WOLF, ME AND A LARGE TEAM OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS, AND WE HAVE BEEN
LEARNING THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAS SUBPOENAED MORE
THAN 30 PEOPLE IN FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP'S ORBIT.
THIS IS RELATED TO THEIR
INVESTIGATION LEADING UP TO
JANUARY 6th, YOU KNOW THEIR
EFFORT TO UNCOVER EFFORTS TO
SUBVERT THE 2020 ELECTION.
THERE ARE A LOT OF BIG NAMES ON
THE LIST OF FOLKS WHO ARE
RECEIVING SUBPOENAS.
THEY INCLUDE PEOPLE LIKE BILL
STEPIEN, TRUMP'S FORMER CAMPAIGN
MANAGER, SHAWN DOELMAN, FORMER
CFO OF THE CAMPAIGN, DAN SKAV
VEAN FOE, FORMER DEPUTY CHIEF OF
STAFF, AND BRIAN JACK WHO WORKED
AS THE WHITE HOUSE POLITICAL
DIRECTOR.
ALL THESE FOLKS EITHER DECLINED
TO COMMENT TO CNN OR COULD NOT
BE REACHED FOR COMMENT.
BUT THIS IS AN INDICATION OF HOW
WIDE THIS IS GROWING, WOLF.
>> SO WHAT DOES THIS TELL YOU
ABOUT THE STATE OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S INVESTIGATION RIGHT
NOW?
>> WOLF, CLEARLY THIS IS AN
INVESTIGATION THAT IS
INTENSIFYING.
WE KNOW THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
RIGHT NOW IS ON THE CUSP OF THIS
QUIET PERIOD, THIS PERIOD WHERE
THEY DON'T WANT THE TAKE ANY
OVERT ACTIONS IN POLITICALLY
SENSITIVE INVESTIGATIONS THAT
CAN BE SEEN AS INFLUENCING THE
OUTCOME OF THE INVESTIGATION.
BUT THEY WANTED TO SCOOP UP A
LOT OF INFORMATION FROM A LOT OF
FOLKS.
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT SUBPOENAS
THAT ENCOME PUS A WIDE RANGE OF
ISSUE, EVERYTHING FROM TRUMP'S
POLITICAL FUND-RAISING SAVE
AMERICA PAC TO THE FAKE ELECTOR
SCHEME TO THE EFFORTS TO SET UP
THE JANUARY 6th RALLY WHERE
TRUMP SPOKE.
SO IT'S CLEAR THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS LOOKING FOR A WIDE
ARRAY OF INFORMATION RIGHT NOW,
WOLF.
>> SARA, I WANT YOU TO STAY WITH
US.
I ALSO WANT TO BRING IN THE
STATE ATTORNEY FOR PALM BEACH
COUNTY IN FLORIDA, DAVE
ARONBERG.
DAVE, AS YOU HEARD, MORE THAN 30
PEOPLE IN TRUMP'S ORBIT HAVE
BEEN SUBPOENAED BY THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IN RECENT DAYS.
JUST HOW MUCH OF AN ESCALATION
DOES THIS REPRESENT IN THIS
OVERALL INVESTIGATION?
>> A BIG ONE, WOLF.
NOW WE KNOW WHAT STEVE BANNON
WAS REFERRING TO WHEN HE SAID
PUBLICLY THAT THERE WERE 35 MAGA
LEADERS WHO HAD THEIR HOME
RAIDED.
WE COULDN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT HE
MEANT.
BECAUSE THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN OUT
IN THE PUBLIC AND WE DIDN'T SEE
THAT.
WELL, WHAT HE DID WAS CONFUSE
SEARCH WARRANTS WITH SUBPOENAS.
BUT, STILL, SUBPOENAS ARE A BIG
DEAL.
AND THE TIMING IS NOT A
COINCIDENCE, AS SARA SAID, THIS
COMES RIGHT BEFORE THE 60-DAY
QUIET PERIOD BEFORE THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS WHEN DOJ TRIES NOT TO
INFLUENCE AN ELECTION.
THAT'S WHY THIS ALL CAME ALL AT
ONCE.
BUT THE FACT THAT BANNON AND
OTHER MAGA LEADERS SEEM SHOCKED
THAT THIS HAPPENED SHOWS TO ME
THAT MERRICK GARLAND HAS LULLED
MANY IN TRUMP WORLD INTO A FALSE
SENSE OF SECURITY.
THIS IS THE KIND OF SLOW BUILD
THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND
HAS BEEN KNOWN FOR IN HIS
PROSECUTORIAL CAREER.
IT'S LIKE THAT BOILING FROG THAT
DOESN'T REALIZE THE TEMPERATURE
HAS BEEN TURNED UP UNTIL TOO
LATE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK THESE
INVESTIGATORS FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ARE INTERESTED IN
FROM THESE KEY TRUMP ALLIES LIKE
HIS FORMER CAMPAIGN MANAGER AND
FORMER DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF?
>> I THINK THE KEY FOCUS ON IS
THE FAKE ELECTOR SCHEME BECAUSE
I THINK THAT COULD BE THE
EASIEST IN WHICH TO CHARGE MAGA
LEADERS.
BECAUSE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
INCLUDING TRUMP, WHO KNEW THAT
THE LISTS OF ALTERNATE ELECTORS
WERE NOT LEGITIMATE AND KNEW
THAT THEY WERE BEING SUBMITTED
TO GOVERNMENT BODIES, COULD BE
CHARGED WITH CONSPIRACY TO
DEFRAUD THE UNITED STATES, ALSO
OBSTRUCTION OF AN OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING.
REMEMBER THERE WAS A WELL
RESPECTED FEDERAL JUDGE WHO SAID
IT WAS MORE LIKELY THAN NOT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT COMMITTED BOTH
THOSE CRIMES.
PLUS I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT THE FINANCIAL CRIMES
"THE SAVE AMERICA PAC."
FOR THE WE BUILD THE WALL
CHARITY SCAM.
BECAUSE, WOLF, FINANCIAL SCHEMES
ARE EASIER TO PROVE THAN OTHERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE FOCUSED ON PAPER
TRAILS.
PEOPLE LIE, BUT DOCUMENTS DO
NOT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING THIS IS
QUITE AN ESCALATION BY THE U.S.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AFTER IT
RECEIVED A LOT OF CRITICISM,
ISN'T IT?
>> YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
I THINK DEMOCRATS IN PARTICULAR
HAVE BEEN CRITICAL.
WE HEARD SOME MEMBERS OF THE
JANUARY 6th SELECT COMMITTEE AND
OTHER DEMOCRATS WERE CRITICAL OF
THE ATTACK MERRICK GARLAND WAS
TAKING.
THEY BELIEVE HE WAS TOO SLOW TO
LOOK INTO FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS ALLIES.
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR FROM THE
LATEST SUBPOENA ACTION THAT THEY
ARE LOOKING AT A WIDE RANGE OF
PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S ORBIT.
AND, TO YOUR POINT, THAT PEOPLE
MAY LIE BUT DOCUMENTS DON'T,
THEY'RE SEEKING A WIDE RANGE OF
DOCUMENTS FROM THESE FOLKS THAT
THEY ARE SUBPOENAING, AND IN
SOME CASES THEY ARE ALSO SEEKING
TESTIMONY.
>> YOU KNOW, SOME OF THESE
SUBPOENAS ALSO REQUESTED RECORDS
THESE RECIPIENTS HANDED OVER TO
THE HOUSE JANUARY 6th SELECT
COMMITTEE.
SO WHAT ARE THEY TRYING TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF WITH THAT
SPECIFIC REQUEST?
>> WELL, IT DEPENDS.
THE HOUSE COMMITTEE FOR JANUARY
6th WAS LOOKING AT THE ATTEMPTED
INSURRECTION.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO LOOK AT
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO ALSO DRAFT
BEHIND THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
BUT JUST BECAUSE THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE HAS IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT PROSECUTORS ARE GOING TO
GET IT.
AND, SO, THEY WERE PAYING
ATTENTION TO THOSE HEARINGS, AND
THAT'S, I THINK, LED TO THIS
DAY.
A LOT OF US WERE CRITICAL OF
MERRICK GARLAND FOR HIS
TIMIDITY.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE HE WAS JUST
DOING A SLOW BUILD WAITING FOR
THIS MOMENT RIGHT BEFORE THE
60-DAY QUIET PERIOD OCCURRED.